what is up everybody it's four and four
anime here for anime Opera and today I
will be breaking down just how strong
kempachi Zaraki is from the bleach
series kempochi is an absolute monster
when it comes to his combat skills so to
break down this legendary force of brute
strength that is kempachi Zaraki in this
video we will be breaking down
kempachi's strength looking into his
powers abilities fights and more so make
sure to stay tuned for this of course
we've made a load of bleach videos on
the channel now including an hour-long
video covering ichio's power so make
sure to check that video out after this
one link to that is of course in the
video description below now if you do
enjoy these bleaked videos on the
channel and you'd like to see more guys
you know what to do smash that like
button as it really does help us out a
lot if you haven't already make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications of course you can also
follow us on both Twitter and Instagram
at anime or brawl and guys now without
further Ado let's jump into It spoilers
and all so Kenpachi Zaraki is the
captain of the 11th division within the
soul society's military organization the
go Thai 13. he is known for his Fierce
fighting style immense strength and his
love of battle now Kenpachi made his
first appearance in chapter 65 of the
manga and episode 20 of the anime series
kempachi is a tall and muscular man
standing at a whopping six foot seven
inches and weighs 198 pounds he has the
iconic spiky black hair and also has a
distinctive scar running down the left
side of his face which was actually
inflicted on him by none other than
ratsu unahana while kempachi was still a
child kempachi's hair has grown past his
shoulders now and no longer has his
Bells this was 17 months after Eisen was
defeated his eye patch is now also just
a single piece covering only his right
eye which is black and gray in color so
let's look into the personality of the
man kempachi loves a good fight more
than anything and the guy lives for
combat in fact in an effort to prolong
any conflict he even holds back he says
that suffering harm or losing one's life
is simply the cost of a good fight
you've gotta love that attitude man
capachi despite his fondness for
brutality usually ends a fight if his
opponent is too hurt to continue you
know he's not interested in battling
weaklings who can't fight anymore and as
such he does not feel compelled to kill
anyone who is unable to defend
themselves on the other hand Kenpachi
frequently demonstrates his admiration
for those who are able to challenge or
even defeat him the most well-known
example is of course Ichigo Kurosaki
kempachi has regarded him as a member of
his own division ever since each go Del
him his first I guess you could say
known defeat since his match with ratsu
unahana kempachi does consistently
professes his desire for a rematch with
Ichigo every time that they encounter
him and of course despite each goes flat
out refusal to give him said rematch he
does view Ichigo as an ally it's got to
be said though that in battle Kenpachi
does occasionally defy his own logic you
know in an effort to get stronger he
employs a variety of strategies to
contain his power in order to prolong
and you know intensify the battle this
includes battling with just a single
hand now in terms of combat kempachi
does lack a wide range of skills
especially when you compare him to the
other go Tai 13 captains and this is all
mainly because he did not attend the
Shinigami Academy however he more than
made up for his shortcomings with his
sheer strength tenacity and intelligence
and this was all before he even used any
of his sampoctos to true powwow he
became a very skilled combatant through
years of training and experience
allowing him to easily overwhelm his
opponent with simple and direct tactics
he uses just Instinct reflexes and
present observation to fight he has no
predetermined attack style and he
continuously gets better with each and
every encounter this approach to battle
allows him to instantly change his own
tactics to match his opponents making it
near impossible for them to keep up or
predict him it's his own insane and you
know quite frankly monstrous power
combined with the ease to switch things
up on the Fly that easily make kempachi
one of the strongest and most feared
Shinigami in all of the go Tai 13.
strength wise kempachi is just an
absolute Beast he is an incredible high
level of physical strength which is most
frequently demonstrated by his tendency
to repel massively sized weapons and
attacks from his opponents with again
just that single arm his offensive power
enables him to sever buildings with just
a single flick of his wrist and you know
fling opponents back during a weapons
battle he can also easily cut through
the steel hard hiero oven a wrong card
all in all he is pretty much a cheat
code in this respect he has the strength
to kick grown men through walls and grab
ichigo's giant zompoc toe and pull him
in just for an attack of his own he is
also capable of ramming straight through
thick walls without taking any damage
himself obviously when he was chasing
Ichigo which was very very very fun to
see the guy's just a beast man absolute
Beast now it's not just strength
kempachi has very quick and agile
physical speeds for his stature and
build before learning the basics of
shumpo kempachi's own natural
acceleration more than compensated for
his lack of shumpo due to the immense
raw strength that he had in his legs
this enabled him to move quickly enough
to close a wide Gap in distance between
him and his opponent and even appear to
vanish from view he can strike quickly
and repeatedly during combat which makes
it extremely difficult for his opponents
to locate a gap and launch a
counter-attack of their own against him
now sometime after his battle with
unohana in the Thousand-Year blood War
Arc which we will cover later on
canpachi actually did start to develop
some skill in the shumpo technique to
enhance his overall abilities in combat
so let's talk the sword kempachi's
proficiency with the sword has been
refined to almost a masterful degree
this allows him to strike repeatedly
with different attack types and patterns
without any problems at all he always
fights with one hand free only employing
both hands against opponents that he
feels will outmatch him otherwise
examples of this would be neutora and
briefly Ichigo thanks to of course
ichigo's undeveloped talent but great
sword power now when using both hands
Kenpachi uses a technique called ryoden
This is is a clean strike splitting his
opponent in half with both hands on his
zompoc toes Hilt and I can't you can't
even begin to imagine how powerful he is
with both hands you know he is one if
not the most skilled swordsman in all of
the Soul society and is the captain of
the 11th division which of course
focuses on sword fighting now kempachi
hates the idea of using sword skills and
techniques that he hadn't learned
himself but instead gained from others
these techniques and skills he had
picked up are only ever used as a very
last resort now head captain genre usai
Yamamoto had actually compelled kampachi
to practice shinigami's on Jutsu before
he joined the gothai 13 and of course as
a result kempachi of course has some
Proficiency in it he has an
exceptionally high level of skill in
Kendo and can use it to defeat multiple
Shinigami at once this is a really funny
fact here but kempachi's training only
last did a day this was because Central
46 were concerned that you know if he
had finished and mastered it he would
grow way too strong and pose a great
threat to the cerate this is just how
much of a beast kempachi is when it
comes to his swordsmanship now it's not
all swordsmanship while kempachi of
course prefers to use his blade in
battle he has actually shown on numerous
occasions that he is quite dangerous
when fighting bare-handed and has
impressive brawling skills with just one
hand he can easily block an opponent's
strike deliver strong punches and kicks
and quickly take down and toss opponents
so like we mentioned Kim pouch he loves
battle but he will handicap himself and
he has equipment for this for Kenpachi
fighting is absolutely everything and
his preference is that he battles the
strongest opponents for as long as he
can like we mentioned even handicapping
himself to make these challenges more
thrilling and exciting to him in the
process so in order to draw these
battles out for his long as he can he
actually utilizes some equipment to give
his opponent The Edge over him not only
that but this is to challenge himself
and push Beyond his own limits in a
weakened state so the first is his eye
patch this isn't just a visually
striking detail but does actually have a
use so Kenpachi is sporting an eye patch
that was made at his request by the
Shinigami research and development
Institute it also seals the majority of
his Rey ryoku in addition to lowering
his depth awareness and field of view he
wears this because he enjoys fighting so
much that he can't fight most opponents
of full power because he'd easily beat
them however even when wearing this eye
patch he still at least extremely
competitive with most opponents the
second piece of equipment are of course
his Bells kempachi has bells on each of
his hair spikes to further give his
opponent the upper hand only adversaries
whose ryatsu is focused to the point
where it can truly defeat kempachi can
hear their those bowels of course like
we mentioned earlier after the victory
over Eisen kempachi stopped donning
these bells so in terms of equipment
let's look at the obvious kempachi
zompoc toe is called nosarashi which
when translated from Japanese means
weather beaten this links into its
appearance really well so appearance
wise the blade is substantially longer
than the typical zumbocto it's actually
around the size of a nodachi the blade
is also very chipped and looks extremely
worn down however despite its rugged and
tattered look this blade is more than
capable of slicing through nearly
anything with ease and the Hilton braid
of his sword are also both white of
course Kenpachi and the relationship
with his zompoc toe is a very
interesting topic kampachi was the only
member of the go tie 13 who was unable
to perform either of his Blade's
awakened States nor could he identify
the name of his zump October 4 becoming
a captain kempachi was actually unable
to hit The Cry of his sword because of
the Discord between him and it this in
turn harmed both of their abilities
their Discord reduced its spiritual
power making it more vulnerable to
attack however of course after his
battle with Ichigo kempachi wanted to
know more about his zombokto so that he
could grow stronger and understand the
suffering associated with not having a
name as of course being someone who
could relate to this harsh feeling
furthermore later when kempachi had
defeated retsu unohana in combat and had
reawakened his true strength he had at
last heard his zompoc toe which we will
be covering in more detail later on the
video so make sure to stay tuned for
that so before moving forward we must
look back another interesting aspect
when it comes to not only kempachi's
power but also him as a character is
looking into his history as well as the
bond he formed with a very unique
individual for as long as he could
remember he had never had a name so he
finally decided to adopt the surname of
the District he had formally called home
which was Zaraki so Rocky was District
80 of the north alley of rukongai now
just to give you an idea just how bad
this District was section one was the
most orderly and law abiding whereas way
further down the list of districts stood
District 80. district 80 was you know
the worst and most Lawless area of
rukongai you know it was full of robbers
and murderers alike so when kampachi was
a small child living in the rukong guys
alleys he came across as shinigami's
dead body and seized his asachi and
asachi is the name given to the nameless
sampocto that is wielded by the lowest
class of Shinigami who are still
currently in training themselves and are
not actually a part of the go tie 13
just yet So eventually kempachi
imprinted his own soul into the blade
which created his own zampark toe he
gradually honed his swordsmanship
through that time killing many
adversaries along the way now at some
point he ran into yachiro Una honor and
engaged her in combat yachiru unahana is
actually the name Captain retsu unahana
once went by which starts connecting
some dots right now unahana was actually
once the most diabolical criminal in all
of the sole Society hard to believe
right Yamamoto actually sought her out
when putting the go tide 13 together and
she became the first captain of the 11th
division as well as the first kempachi
during a mission she came across a boy
who attacked her on site and the two
went on to fight that boy was none other
than the young kempachi's Iraqi in this
fight kempachi felt Terror for the very
first time and as such he had grown
weary of cutting anything else it was
also the first combat he had ever loved
now he lost to her here because he
unconsciously sealed his power to
prolong the battle an after said battle
he started to adore her after their
fight and wished he could fight like her
later when Kenpachi was a young man he
came across a small girl he gave her the
name yachiru in honor of the one person
he had ever admired this name was given
to the small girl because she displayed
no fear of his sword now yichiro is from
kusajishi's District 79 where her
parents were assassinated not long
before kenpach had shown up it was also
on that day that he assumed the name
kempachi which is given to the strongest
Shinigami in every generation the
Shinigami who has killed the most
adversaries and triumphed in the
greatest of combat now one day he ran
into akaku madarame and Yumi chica Aya
sagawan ikaku was cautioned by yachiro
not to meddle with kempachi while he was
in a good mood but of course ikaku did
not heed the advice the two began to
fight and ikaku was forced to go on the
defensive in order to fend off
kempachi's constant attacks because of
his overwhelming strength ikaku
attempted to overpower our kenpat she is
the two battled on but was of course
unable to do so and even though kempachi
said he was having fun here he did make
the decision to defeat ikaku by striking
him with one single decisive strike
later in front of nearly 200 men of the
division kempachi executed campachi
kaganjo the captain of the gotai 13's
11th division with just a single strike
again kempachi assumed command of that
division as of the third Captain
qualification trial he became the 11th
person to wield the title by killing the
11th division Captain making him the
sole legitimate holder of the title
kempachi now both ikaku and Yumi chica
who had already joined the division and
became Shinigami themselves joined
kempachi the following day at his first
address to his new division so knowing
kenpachi's backstory let's look at the
first time we see him in action which
was against none other than the series
protagonist Ichigo corusci during the
sole Society Arc this fight was truly so
hype and they certainly built it up they
were telling us just how fearsome an
opponent Kenpachi was and at the same
time kempachi was relentlessly hunting
down Ichigo you know the strongest ryoka
who had infiltrated the sole Society to
rescue rookie akuchiki from higher
execution now while pointing out that it
has openings kempachi actually Praises
ichigo's Battle Stance and confesses
that he admires his spiritual pressure
recognizing that Ichigo is still weaker
than him kempachi chooses to give Ichigo
a chance despite the fact he
acknowledges he can see why ikaku had
lost to him now kempachi does something
extremely bold here and something so
boss kempachi actually orders Ichigo to
cut him wherever he wants without
holding back while bearing his chest at
him of course Ichigo was extremely
hesitant to do so while praising Ichigo
for his refusal to assault an unarmed
opponent Kenpachi remarks that it is
only a handicap and advises that Ichigo
should save his compassion for somebody
else kempachi then drops one of the most
boss lines she'd expect from him as he
gives Ichigo the option to kill or be
killed Ichigo finally goes in for the
attack but his strike causes zero damage
to kempachi and actually he ends up
being the one bleeding from the strike
himself at this moment kempachi was
utterly disappointed with Ichigo as he
wanted a worthy opponent to fight
against but of course here Ichigo wasn't
proving to be that in fact he was far
from that as the battle waited on Ichigo
was improving which was pleasing and
exciting kempachi as it had been such a
long time since he fought in a battle
that was worthy of his time however
Ichigo was still struggling to cook
kempachi now after learning that
kempachi couldn't activate the release
stages of his zompoc toe Ichigo did
become overconfident and in turn dropped
his guard he failed to notice and
respect the brute power that was
kempachi Zaraki at this current level
and this resulted in Ichigo not only
having his own zampokto sliced by
kembachi's but he was also left with a
very fatal injury as can partially
simply walked away from the fight
however zongetsu would come to ichigo's
Aid and this battle would reach its epic
climax the moment Ichigo stands up a
strong spiritual pressure rushes over
him kempachi receives a major injury to
his left side from his shoulder down the
side of his chest as a result of
ichigo's attack which of course here
further surprises and excites him after
avoiding ichigo's next bloke kempachi
thrusts his blade into a nearby
structure the fight is just getting
started says kempachi who is grinning
and feeling quite thrilled he adds that
they should prolong the fight now to get
closer to Ichigo he lunges at him and
allows ichigo's blade to gash his face
here's a rocky removes his eye patch and
declares that Ichigo is a worthy
opponent thus it only May makes sense to
fight him at full strength as he is
realizing here that he and Ichigo are
now evenly matched he is also relishing
the overwhelming thrill and exhilaration
of the moment as kempachi takes off his
eye patch his spiritual Powers soars
leaving Ichigo perplexed to like what is
happening Ichigo who is now more
powerful than he has ever been before
declares he would never lose to someone
like hempachi who just fights for
himself after explaining that his power
has surged thanks to him partnering up
with his zompoc toes on Getsu kempachi
thinks this is absurd he queries whether
zonketsu is Ichigo zambocto battling
alongside it and utilizing his might
according to kempachizampokto are merely
weapons of war there are tools and
fighting beside one is an act reserved
for losers who are too scared to go at
it alone they both charge each other in
one final attack while simultaneously
releasing enough spiritual pressure to
bring down all all of the nearby
structures the pair do land finishing
blows on one another Ichigo does fall
first but Kenpachi declares Ichigo the
winner of their battle now this battle
was super important for kenpachi's
growth as it opened his eyes to how he
had been treating his own zombac 2 and
that it wasn't a weakness to work
together with it but it would actually
make him stronger badly injured after
the battle Kenpachi raises his broken
zonpok toe into the air and admits that
he had been ignoring it for the longest
time and that he finally felt that he
wanted to communicate with it this will
truly accelerate kempachi's powers and
abilities later on of course in that
battle we also got to see just how
insane kempachi's spiritual power is
kempachi's Ray ryoku is Monster leveled
even by a captain's standards kampachi
admits that he lacks the ability to
control his spiritual energy which is
always very strong and he must rely on
his eye patch to keep this spiritual
power controlled now now he can still
utilize it freely and in a number of
ways despite this it can have a
wide-ranging mile-long impact and send
people there into a condition of
disorientation and immobility now when
Kenpachi uses his energy the sheer might
of it will do a great deal of harm
demolishing the region around him and
throwing more vulnerable foes into the
air this can also block or deflect the
majority of opponents attacks and
abilities kempachi's Spirit Powers
intensity also serves as a kind of armor
protecting him against anyone who isn't
at least as powerful as him he of course
initially showed this in the fight
against Ichigo in the soul society and
like we mentioned earlier he chooses to
suppress his Spirit energy using this
eye patch but prior to receiving the eye
patch kempachi had actually
unconsciously concealed the majority of
his true power for centuries and though
suppressed his fighting prowess is never
visibly hampered by his energy ceiling
eye patch of course following unohana's
defeat hempachi significantly
strengthens his command over his
rariatsu so Kenpachi is far more than
Brew's strength he has frequently shown
a remarkably excellent understanding of
many situations despite his dislike for
any plan making when it comes to battle
kenpachi's capacity to comprehend
Concepts he has had no first-hand
experience with outstanding even biakia
himself additionally he has the ability
to spot flaws in his adversaries
fighting strategies and assault patterns
as well as to swiftly shift and modify
his own strategies to effectively
counter them we saw this in his fight
with kaname tozen in the sole Society
Arc he allowed tozen to strike him in
order to catch his opponent off guard
and strike back at him himself as he was
defenseless against tozen's bonkai that
took away all of his senses except the
feeling of touch kempachi himself is
highly perceptive about the human nature
he is able to pick out minor differences
between people and understands the
motive equations behind their acts he
even accurately identified both karame
tozen and gin ichimaru as the only
captains who were frightened of dying
back to the fight with tozen it was his
excellent instincts for impending danger
which let him avoid tozan's attacks
while still under the influence of his
Bankai the reason his strategy worked
here is down to the combination of his
own physical state and his resilience
now you can very much liken kempachi to
that of a Berserker Kenpachi frequently
shows no symptoms of Agony despite
having numerous slash and Pierce wounds
on his body instead he tends to overlook
the majority of the wounds he receives
during combat during this battle with
tozan he of course allowed himself to be
stabbed in order to seize tozan's blade
and counteract the effects of his bunkai
this insanity or Brilliance depending on
how you look at it is continued in his
fight against the fifth rank to Sparta
noitoro kempachi sustained several slash
wounds during his encounter with noise
he was even impaled and nearly beheaded
however Kenpachi showed no sight
impairment to his fighting ability
noitora even noted that most individuals
would have already been dead at this
point their fight was actually a really
good one and another display of the
Monstrous force that is kempachi's Iraqi
so noitara makes an early mistake he
tells kempachi that he will never be cut
by his blade unfazed by this kempachi
fights noitora even more fiercely much
to the surprise of their Sparta when
noitare successfully avoids an attack
kampachi says that it must have been
risky for him to do so neutora simply
brushes this off as a reaction and
Carries on with the fight until kempachi
stabs him in the eye covered by his eye
patch here claiming that he has never
encountered an opponent whose eyes and
neck could not be cut noitora who is
unaffected however shows the fragments
of his Hollow mask and the hole that was
hidden beneath his eye patch this
becomes a match of who can cut who can
and party eventually lands once sending
noitora into a rage and he begins to
fight with much more ferocity until
kampachi's eye patch is then knocked off
noitor explodes in a fit of Wrath after
Kenpachi explains the significance of
his eye patch when noitora inquires as
to how it feels for an Espada to unleash
their zompoc toe for the first time
kampachi Simply Smiles and responds that
he has a nice riyatsu and that it feels
as though his ryatsu is sharpening his
sword the fight between the two goes on
is kempachi is forced to use his last
resort which was the Kendo training he
had received though he acknowledges it
had been a while since he has utilized
Kendo he decides to do so in this battle
although of course reluctantly noitara
becomes confused so kempachi decides to
explain his Kendo training however the
explanation is short-lived kempachi
swings his blade down as neutora charges
after him growing bored with the
argument here kempachi holding his sword
in both hands strikes noiatora with a
strong wrong blow that nearly Cuts him
in two removing several of his Limbs and
causes a fatal wound to his chest he
turns to leave after being surprised to
see the Espada still alive noitori yells
that the fight is not over but as we
know campachi finds no sport in you know
finishing weakened opponents who can't
defend themselves so here he simply
chooses to walk away this understandably
angers noyatora who continues to goad
kempachi until he finally decides to
give the Espada what he wants and
delivers the finishing blow killer fight
that one and I just remembered it being
so hype when I first saw it kampachi is
just a demonic presence that you want
more and more of it had also been a
while since we last saw him in action
and this battle did not disappoint at
all we got to see him push to his limits
and we also got to see how he had
progressed since we last saw him in
battle and that's the thing with
kempachi he's a lot like Ichigo in the
sense of you know the more damage he
sustains the stronger he comes back once
healed again and I likened this to the
Saiyans from the Dragon Ball franchise
and how they get stronger after
suffering a loss it does make the
hopeful rematch between kenbachi and
Ichigo all the more mouthwashering
though I'm sure Ichigo will stay way
clear of that situation so we of course
see Kenpachi in the fight against Yami
where he continues to show off just how
amazing and terrifying he is when it
comes to combat I for one would most
certainly never want to come up against
Kenpachi as an opponent that's for sure
however we're gonna move on to the
events in the Thousand-Year blood War
Arc here where we got to see the real
and major improvements in not only
kenpachi's power but in his character
too so we first see Kenpachi in this Arc
in a very typically hype Kenpachi moment
kempachi makes his entrance by facing
yuhar while carrying the bodies of three
Stern ritters on his shoulders kempachi
is asked how he vanquished the three of
them so quickly but he dismisses this
and moves in to attack yuha while
sprinting forward here you are blocks
the sword assault with his arm causing a
massive shock wave that devastates the
landscape around them now this fight
doesn't go down too well yuha who is now
holding the bloody Captain up by the
throat has effortlessly defeated
campachi he claims that he had thought
of the captain as one of their five
special War potentials and comes to the
conclusion that he is overestimated
kempachi calling him weak and that's how
much of a beast yuhar is by the way you
know to Simply disregard kempachi as
just weak and that he overestimated him
wow just wow luckily head captain genre
usai Yamamoto appears and grabs kempachi
from yuha's hands sparring kempachi from
any further suffering Kenpachi is said
to have narrowly avoided dying after the
struggle for the soul Society being left
in a comatose state now after a few days
and recovering from his injuries what
happens next for kempachi is huge for
his growth so huge that the kempachi we
get after this fight is nothing thing
like we have ever seen from him in a
very very hype way so ratsu unohana is
instructed by the new captain Commander
shunsui kiroko to lead kempachi to the
lowest level of the central gray
underground prison so that he will be
trained to become much stronger and
attain his full potential the two
captains start their combat to the death
after it is revealed that they have both
previously left physical scars on one
another and it's here we get to see just
how much of a beast unahana is too for
the longest time we only ever Associated
her as a Healer you know being the
captain of squad 4 but here we get to
see that she is way more than just a
Healer in fact she is one of the most
strongest captains ever going off that
notion we actually made a video ranking
the captains from Bleach weakest to
strongest if you want to see where both
unohana and Kenpachi ranked in our list
a link to that video will be in the
description below I think he'll be very
surprised so back to the fight unohana
completely overwhelms kempachi
deflecting his attacks with her free
hand and legs as the latter is on the
losing end of this fight unohana cannot
help but complement him for taking off
his eye patch at the very beginning of
their fight but she points out that by
doing so he is also battling at the
limit of his abilities here she labels
kempachi as weak and continues to stab
him with a concealed knife she claims
that those who only fight with one hand
without using the other for anything
else do not look like they enjoy
fighting to her kempachi says she has
changed from the time he used to look up
to her and belittles her for utilizing
tactics she had not used in their
previous fights here kempachi's sword is
knocked out of his hands and unahana
pins him against the wall before
claiming that she hasn't changed and
that he simply didn't allow her the
opportunity to utilize her tactics the
last time they battled kampachi who
admits that he had admired her says that
until this battle with unohana he had
never expected experience fear it was at
this point that he decided he wanted to
fight like her unohana then stabs
Kenpachi in the throat as he becomes
aware that he might die before defeating
her when kempachi momentarily passes out
something catches his eye and awakens
him unohana notices this and inquires as
to what happened as it appeared that he
had briefly lost Consciousness kempachi
keeps fighting her despite her question
and whatever had captured his attention
and I like this fight for Kenpachi as
there is almost a deeper more emotional
feel to it rather than his pure battle
lust unohana is the Pinnacle of his
respect and the one person he feels he
must defeat above any other to be the
best now Kenpachi is continuously
wounded and knocked out as the struggle
goes on he eventually lands some damage
on unohana as she continues to heal him
he realizes that he is behaving on
Instinct now when before he was simply
responding to her sword he continues
oblivious that the unconscious just
boundaries he set for himself during
their initial conflict are now being
released that every time he regains
Consciousness it feels like he has been
born again unaware that each time a seal
on his power is released he is reborn as
a stronger version of himself and that
at last he is returning to his former
self and now he rushes back to clash
blades with her when he first faced
unohana kempachi had experienced the
thrill of fighting on the edge and was
far removed from his daily encounters
with weaklings she was the first person
he encountered who was at a comparable
level to the power of him kampachi
didn't want to kill her because that
would mean that he would never get to
experience this level of Joy again so he
sealed his own power deep within himself
just so that he could match her what
unahana was doing here was removing
these seals that he had created so that
he could finally become the real
kempachi she knew he was she knew that
in doing so it would result in her own
death but it was the fact that her death
was the only way kempachi could move
forward so back to their battle despite
receiving a severe hit unahana pushes
kempachi back while healing herself and
begins to use her Bankai which sadly we
never got to see by the way I bet it was
boss now kempachi is thoroughly enjoying
himself as the combat heats up and he
Chuckles uncontrollably he thinks to
himself that this is actual fighting and
is appreciative to unohana unohana is
stabbed in the chest as kempachi finally
wins over the one Warrior he truly ever
looked up to kempachi draws back his
blade and drops it as unohana thanks him
while passing away in his arms as his
opponent loses Consciousness and passes
away aware that this is the last
encounter with her he'll ever get
kempachi yells out in Fury pleading with
her not to die suddenly campachi hears a
voice as he turns to face the voice he
discovers that it was his zompoc toe
crying out to him out of the blue the
zombato he believed had no name finally
responds to him after all this time time
his sword is finally able to speak to
him he can hear his zompokto telling him
that he has always been beside him in
battle watching him and remaining loyal
to him it introduces itself as nozarashi
now there is another big twist involving
nozurashi but we won't get into that
juicy one till a bit later on in
kampachi's story so again stay tuned for
that one so kempachi moves towards
yachiro after sensing a decrease in her
riyatsu he bursts straight through a
wall and finds the stern Ritter only to
feel disappointment the Grammy is the
one causing trouble here Grammy again is
another opponent who is foolish enough
to claim that he cannot be cut by
kempachi like I I just feel like that is
like a statement that never ends well
when they claim to lay down that
challenge so Grammy elevates the ground
to create a platform for their conflict
kempachi charges towards Grammy after
hearing his insult but his blade is
halted now Grammy's power is that he has
the ability to bring into reality
anything that he can imagine here him
imagine that his skin was like iron and
thus resistant kenpachi's blade kampachi
however declares he can cut through
anything Grammy can conceive after
hearing Grammy explain his powers to him
Grammy of course boasts arrogantly that
he won't need any of his fingers to
defeat kempachi instead he'll just use
his mind however his strategies have
little effect on the new and improved
kempachi Grammy is just one of those he
had always believed that he was you know
the strongest therefore he never felt
the need to compete because he believed
that he had nothing to prove however
kampachi has brought out his lust for
battle and now he wants to crush
kempachi however this doesn't go to plan
as kempachi of course lands a cut on him
reaffirming that there is nothing indeed
that kempachi Zaraki can not cut so
their battle rages on and we get to see
Grammy's powers on full display as well
as kempachi's new and improved State
Grammy is of course flustered by
kempachi and his relentlessness to
attack but pulls out his big move
Kenpachi keeps attacking Remy constantly
taking advantage of his inaction to
react quick enough and repeatedly slices
at him while also cutting through the
constant structures Grammy has made a
puzzled Kenpachi inquires whether Grammy
is imagining his own demise after
cutting him multiple times after turning
to his wounds Grammy thanks Kenpachi for
bringing this to his attention and
before making a copy of himself declares
that he will unveil his most powerful
technique Remy warns that the Clone will
survive any of kempachi's attacks and
point out a massive meteorite that is
heading straight for the cerate kempachi
tells his sword it's great to find
something he hasn't yet slashed and
calls it nosarashi as Grammy declares
this attack will destroy both kempachi
and the entire cerate here kempachi
claims that Grammy is the one who is
powerless and leaps at the meteorite
when Grammy explains to him that he
could not destroy the meteorite because
it already exists Kenpachi of course
smashes the meteorite by releasing the
actual form of noserashi causing p is to
fall all around him as he stands tall
with his sheikhai Finally Revealed
kampachi boldly as ever claims he can
simply cut through anything after Grammy
Brands him a monster for being able to
destroy a meteorite with a single blow
Grammy also declares this means he will
just have to kill kempachi with
something that has no form and encloses
him in a sizable pocket of space
surrounding kempachi with more of his
own clones Grammy explains to campachi
that he would die a slow and horrible
death in space But as he does so
kempachi Cuts clean through one of
Grammy's clones cutting himself out of
the Void in the process kampachi does
get caught in a massive explosion as the
other clones latch onto him but he makes
it out with only moderate Burns and
scratches to his own body here Grammy
sees this as further evidence of
kempachi just being like that of a
monster and declares that he will grow
stronger than kempachi himself now as
his transformation takes place his veins
intrude he then races at kempachi but as
his body tries to catch up with his
transformation his body starts to tear
itself apart in mid-air Kenpachi taunts
Grammy as he plummets to the ground
below for mistaking him for a monster
and losing as a result of that thought
ironically becoming a monster like
kempachi was too much for him to handle
also interestingly after the conclusion
of this battle kempachi's Lieutenant
yachiro had vanished we can assume that
this is because she has actually merged
with kempachi's zompoc toe because she
was always a part of his power that was
waiting to be awakened this is an
interesting thought right so with his
shikai seeing the light of day in the
series let's look into it prior to his
battle with unohana before kempachi knew
its name the sole Society thought that
nosarashi was forced into a constantly
released condition due to compachie's
overwhelming ryatsu however we know now
that that is not the case so drink is
his she kind israeli's command and
nozarashi transforms into a big ax War
Cleaver hybrid thing with a lengthy
cloth wrapped handle as soon as it is
freed as we saw in his battle with the
stern Ritter Grammy knows Rashi can
easily destroy a large meteorite with
just one attack while it's in its
release State and this is due to its
incredibly increased attack power its
cutting ability is also substantially
increased enabling kempachi to easily
cut through the bodies of his
adversaries and even the fabric of space
itself so the next significant encounter
that sheds light on kempachi is in his
final battle with the stern Ritter
Gerard Valkyrie when he arrives to help
captains toshurohit sagaya and biochia
kuchiki he cuts off Gerard's forearm
right away however the stern Ritter has
a special ability called The Miracle the
miracle is an ability that Gerard
himself has described as the power to
create miracles on himself through
thoughts feelings and his own desires
his ability allows him to swing the tide
in his favor through through probability
manipulation if Gerard is in a battle
where the odds are strongly stacked
against him the miracle allows him to
succeed regardless of how bad a
situation he is in nevertheless kempachi
is persistent and fights to close the
gap between their strengths kempachi and
Gerard continue to fight with kempachi
gradually losing the advantage as Gerard
points out the diminishing force of his
blows before slamming him to the ground
here kempachi is then confronted by none
other than yachiro or I guess we could
call her noseorashi you know the spirit
of his unpok toe she informs him that
the fun is only just getting started
nosarashi remarks that kempachi could
cut down anyone if he utilized her
properly before explaining that this is
the power known as Bankai while
explaining this an energy starts to pour
down kempachi's arm from where she had
touched him now kempachi's Bankai
doesn't have a name but when activated
kempachi's bunkai sends out a massive
surge of energy potent enough to destroy
neighboring structures campachi
resembles it only in this form because
of his red complexion numerous black
marks all over his face and the horns on
his forehead his sword also changes to a
shorter more Jagged variant of its
shikai state that resembles a crude
Cleaver now kempachi's bonkai gives him
a significant boost in physical power
and cutting ability and this is the only
bunkai we are aware of that really
Alters the Wheeled estate mentally and
physically as well in this guy's
kembachi resembles a demon Berserker who
has gained tremendous strength and power
however he does Act without regard for
his own life and in a frenzy of pure
wrath he is almost fully devoured when
his bunkai is activated in his bonkai
form kempachi appears to be able to cut
anything proving what yachiro earlier
told him to be true this is a theme that
is frequently brought up throughout most
of his battles as his opponents
constantly boast about having steel skin
that cannot be cut only for kempachi to
prove them wrong here he then starts to
attack Gerard completely cutting off his
arm Kenpachi makes an attempt to
continue the fight but his right arm
abruptly tears as we find out that
yachiro was unable to contain the amount
of force he produced causing it to
overwhelm him this demonstrates how
untapped kempachi's power is now Gerard
attacks kempachi without warning and
this reverts him to his regular form
Captain he isagaya approaches Gerard who
overwhelms him however kempachi is able
to flip Gerard over and sever his feet
thus the battle ends in Victory and
that's all we have on kempachi's battles
when it comes to powerhouses kampachi
Zaraki is just on another level entirely
he is incredibly tuned to combat his
swordsmanship is brutal as is his expert
battle senses words that are chosen to
describe his power are words such as
Supernatural and immeasurable which
really gives us an understanding of just
how much of a fearsome presence he
really is the guy is just an absolute
force and a master of combat the other
captains tend to keep him just like
arm's length so I hope this video allows
you to understand just how strong he is
by pointing out the key points in his
story and by highlighting his powers and
abilities let us know in the comment
section below which of his fights you
enjoyed the most like I mentioned at the
start of the video we have also made a
load of bleach videos on the channel now
including that hour-long video on
ichigo's power so make sure to check
that video out link to that is of course
in the description below of course if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more bleach videos on the channel
make sure to let us know by Smashing
that like button if you haven't already
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future anime or broad videos remember
you can also follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime or Brawn thanks again
and we can't wait to see you in the next
one till next time take care yourselves
peace